you've uh you've talked about national
divorce a few times i've i've seen a
couple videos recently where you're
responding to articles
it's kind of cool
um
can you can you
talk about this idea of national divorce
and as it stands today
uh arguing for it maybe and if you could
just out of curious in the context of
those videos if you can steal man an
argument against
uh so i was the first one to kind of
bring this issue back into the national
um
conversation i wrote a piece for
observer in 2016. then jesse kelly had a
piece a few months after that daver boy
just recently did a piece on his stub
stack earlier this year
and it's become enough of a
mainstreamed idea that um paleontology
outlets like national review have felt
the need to respond to them
so the point being that america has had
at least two cultures since the
beginning and that there's absolutely no
reason
and these cultures in recent years and
this was in 2016 not mentioned 2021 have
been increasingly antagonistic toward
one another and have even lost the
ability to communicate they're using
language in different ways
and that there's no reason for this to
continue any uh further
um and you know just
you live your life we'll live hours and
you know good goodbye and good luck
there's no harm no ill will
um
now there's lots of arguments against
them some of this are
are completely i think stupid uh the
stupidest one
is well that's what china wants okay
well i i mean i'm not going to live my
life saying i'm just going to do the
opposite of whatever china wants that
that's that's not
logic that's not a good pathway now i'm
not saying that right or wrong but
that's not a reason one way or another
yeah you bring up china or russia you
know that's exactly what uh china and
russia want but sort of the strong way
to phrase that
is um
it weakens
america like not just
the one america but
like both sides in the divorce will be
much weaker than they individually were
together
so in that sense not that you have to
care about what china thinks but like
it's a step but it's a big step
backwards yes i think in the short term
it is absolute big step backwards in
terms of power uh there's no question
that
you know when you're trying to
re-establish a society there's going to
be a transition period that transition
is going to be costly uh each side
starts wondering wait a minute why are
we still doing this we don't have to
anymore we're not living with them so on
and so forth so that's going to be a
concern
um i don't think that the whole point of
america
uh or even a large primary point of
america is to be a bullwork against
chinese power and there's gonna be very
few people on earth you know given my
work who have as much uh informed hatred
and contempt for the chinese government
as i do uh certainly um you know next to
the north korean people maybe the people
from um eritrea there's few populations
who i'm as worried about as uh the
people under the rule of the red chinese
my steel man argument is
there's no way this is gonna be peaceful
because the lines don't separate out
well so all you're doing is basically
just replicating the problem because the
disparity isn't between you know like
during the civil war north and south
it's like it's between new york city and
upstate new york between chicago
downstate chicago once you get outside
of la and like sacramento uh california
in many ways like kentucky so it doesn't
make sense so that's a strong argument i
mean you've talked about that this
process would be painful right it can't
be pain and we're not just talking about
violence it could be just
even the civil war you could divide it
clean somewhat cleanly
obviously the kind of national divorce
you might be suggesting
is yeah people are living amongst each
other so you have to literally it's
complicated right so that is a very
strong argument
i think a cogent argument against it
two is
it's not just china it's that there's a
lot of
bad actors in the world who maybe aren't
like china certainly wants to carry
itself and have an appearance at least
on the world stage as civilized and a
leader there's lots of smaller countries
who without us
are going to feel comfortable doing some
very nefarious things um and
they're not going to be scared of us
anymore and so that would be bigger
concern in many regards than china so i
think that's a reasonable one
um it could be that both sides if this
happens are gonna instead of work toward
better
the things that make each side bad would
get worse yeah and that's you know
having those pushed towards the
malevolent extremes is i think a very
legitimate criticism and a concern
i mean as you suggested there's no
guarantee that won't happen correct at
all
also
there's a i think a reasonable argument
to make is like are you america
just as a symbol and the myth of america
and i don't mean myth in a negative
sense do you really want to throw that
in the garbage
like this meant a lot for a lot of
people and a lot for history you're just
going to be like okay good
good work we're we're done here let's
shut the lights so that's i think a
reasonable argument so those are the
um biggest ones i would say and and
still
what is the case for national divorce
and
along which lines so like um
in making the case for national divorce
if it is desired
based on which kind of ideas do you
think it should be
uh carried through i honestly i don't
know that it has to be idea based like
for example when czechoslovakia broke up
when norway and sweden broke up it
wasn't really ideological
it was more cultural
so
i always say divorced into two but it
would probably make more sense if it was
like five
uh because the northeast certainly new
england has their own culture
the west coast has their own kind of
culture i don't know the thing is
in any kind of um persuasion technique
right like once people are start
it there's there's a difference between
convincing someone they want to buy a
car and what features you want so if
you're at the point where we're arguing
about the features then my work here is
done you know what i mean like i don't
have a dog in the fight in terms of what
it's going to look like i just want to
get to the point where you're at least
considering seriously the idea of
breaking up america and i would
encourage people to go look at my
article to see
which i'm sure the
arguments still hold uh five years later
do you have a kind of vision of which of
the two or which of the five
like do you actually have specific
cultures i'll tell you exactly yeah if i
told you and everyone listening in 2014
we weren't that long ago it wasn't long
ago
which of these two things is more likely
to happen
texas secedes
or declare secession from america or
donald trump gets elected president
everyone's voting for texas
like
in terms of prediction which is more
likely so we had this one so it's not
all unlikely we're gonna have this one i
don't know if that logic carries through
you can't just say
here's an unlikely thing that happened
therefore anything can happen i just
said you just earlier said anything had
happened this episode didn't you life is
suffering i wasn't listening to half the
things you're saying you said it i said
it yes you said anything can happen i'm
definitely not here i'm like you with
podcasts i do a podcast but i don't
listen to it
okay
so yeah yeah it can happen but in which
i guess i'm asking would you stay in
texas a hundred percent sure and i'd run
for office probably it'd be fun
no i'm gonna be the first president of
texas
i attended a debate between uh yaran
brooks and
joram
hazoni i don't know if you know who that
is the nationalist guy yeah he wrote a
book called the virtue of nashville i
read that book
and then actually did a podcast with
them they did a debate
oh they both run here
okay it was quite interesting and i
tried to wear my michael mal's hat
so the you're wearing it now
you borrowed that from me yeah
um
it's funny because the metaphor applies
across
all of these level of collectivism so he
was arguing that for the power of nation
so you he would be arguing against
national divorce but he was also
arguing for marriage the power of actual
marriage between individuals like
um
i think he's a conservative and what i
really like about him is there's a clear
philosophy of conservatism that he
expresses and i think a lot of people
get behind that philosophy because uh to
me like conservatism and liberalism
often is very kind of used loosely yes
he has a clear philosophy that he's
expressing there and is grounded in
tradition he has a lot of value in
tradition and so
it's the thing you said about america
like one of the one of the arguments
against national divorce is like listen
um we've been at it for a while like
there is a lot of value in the fact that
we've been at it for a while don't just
throw it all away all the time so he
says like philosophically he seems in a
lot of walks of life
revolution is should be um avoided as
much as possible i agree
and so it's kind of interesting
so he makes the case that there's
something fundamentally powerful about
the nation
that we uh it's a it's a
it's a nice way to group a culture
and
so national divorce i guess goes against
that i mean do you find some aspect of
the virtue of nationalism as you will
put it
powerful
well powerful and in in a good sense or
in a good sense so sorry yeah in a good
sense like well yeah it brings out the
best in humans i know at the best but it
certainly brings out good things i have
that line i always say about i love my
country i hate the government because i
love my country yeah
so there is a love of country i think
it's value but i i don't know that
that's the i think
it's also the case because the country
happens to be america like i don't know
if i was living in you know whatever i
don't want to insult someone's country
um uh canada yeah if i was living in
canada i don't know that'd be the truth
this is a guy who calls basically every
other country country yeah
that's true that's that's the fact yeah
yeah so it's either you're either
there's two types of countries texas or
shitholes um oh wow you went full texas
so you you you're okay burning the
northeast to the ground at this point
okay i'm hoping for it i'm going to call
hope
what they've done to new york city i
will never forgive these people
um and i hope that they suffer
enormously uh consequences for what
they've done to new york
um it's unforget it's unconscionable uh
the assault they've done and and no
remorse over how many uh creative
outlets that they've destroyed yes the
cultural hub cultural center of the
world
new york was the sim this was the place
where you go to put up your shingle and
and move the needle and make things
happen uh and i would understand if it
was like okay we gotta suffer through
this for a year but we're gonna make
sure all these businesses have a
kind of safety net to make sure that
they kind of get through and survive
this which they did to the banks in 2008
for example um and i'm saying this is an
anarchist and there was none of that so
i i
burn it down and salt the earth uh it's
it's because it's like watching like a
zombie it's on it's unnatural it's it's
an abomination
so i mean sort of on the on the white
pill side of things i i don't know about
you maybe i have a sense that uh both
silicon valley that for me personally
maybe i have the same intensity of
feeling as you do about
new york it's just disappointing to see
it
be consumed with cynicism
and a lot of other paralyzing forces but
i still have hope for that place i think
it's maybe it's the
uh
yoram kind of tradition hope that
through momentum
this the strong reemerges
so like i have hope for new york i i
think new york will continue like
not maybe on a scale of years but a
scale of decades
it would be ups and downs where it
reemerges as a cultural center i just
can't imagine a place like new york is
like paris
there's going to be long stretches of
time
where it leads the world
paris has not been a cultural hub for a
very long time yeah
yeah you know the days of matisse and
picasso and gertrude stein or long gone
it's still it still is a hub even london
isn't like yeah
you know you're not there but what it is
then london is still london paris is
still paris it's not the paris of old
right london of all london is still a
place
it's a it's a tech hub it's a fashion
hub it's a music hub i mean it's still a
pretty strong hub yeah but not like
during the beatles era right it's not
like or during the sex pistols era but
that's it could be just us romanticizing
the past because what is a hub then no
it's not rem there's not romanticizing
the past because a hub is
the place where everyone on earth are
our eyes are on you so in the late 60s
the british and in the mid 60s you see
the british invasion you know the kinks
and all these other bands coming out of
uh great britain like they were the
innovators this was the this was the
place that was happening well in that
sense like and brooklyn you know 15
years ago
but i guess uh maybe in that sense in
the 21st century geographical hubs are
becoming a thing of the past so like um
you can be a hub in the digital space
now so like it's not maybe you'll never
have
i don't think i think there will always
be
i mean what i'm saying digital space
makes it easier for let's suppose
cleveland to be a hub right because all
you need like 10 people who happen to
live in cleveland or you know akron was
a hub a minor high all it takes is 10 to
50 people to create a yeah and maybe
even less maybe it's just uh two or
three
affordable i mean there's been no
shortage of articles talking about
austin and what's happening here um and
i know some of joe's plans and and you
and i and and blair and and all these
other people that you know my buddy
andrew heaton moved here he's just one
of the best people i know it's just i'm
really really excited
you